und ich dachte wir würden mitten im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts niemals
mehr ein krieg erleben müssen wie es das
ganze überhaupt möglich ich weiß jeder
hat so was ähnliches in den letzten
wochen irgendwann einmal von den meisten
menschen um sich herum und in den medien
gehört alle dachten dass kriege der
vergangenheit angehören würden es schien
als hätte der pazifistischen geist john
lennons vollends von uns europäern
besitz ergriffen und was alle dabei
vergessen haben jeder john lennon trifft
erst seine yoko ono und dann seinen
mörder der europäische yoko ono moment
war die invasion in der ukraine und die
angst vor der mörder geht nun um
plötzlich ist der anti militärische
konsens in der europäischen union
verschwunden mit nachrichten wie diese
treten wir in eine neue ära ein
deutschland musste seine militärausgaben
im rahmen einer historischen zeitenwende
praktisch alle europäischen regierungen
haben ähnliche ankündigungen gemacht und
ja wir haben es mit einer massiven
kehrtwende der gesamten europäischen
politik zu tun dieses video meine liegen
zuschauer soll etwas ganz besonderes
werden mit diesem video möchten wir euch
jene perspektiven geben die olaf scholz
seinem volk in der zeitenwende rede
eigentlich hätte vermitteln soll denn
was sollen wir uns eigentlich unter
diesen abstrakten begriff einer
zeitenwende vorstellen was bedeutet sie
für unseren kontinent und unser land für
unsere gesellschaft was bedeutet sie für
unser aller leben wie sollen sie mit ihr
umgehen und welche zukunft erwartet uns
nun wie können wir sie zu unserem
triumph machen und ihre auslöser
verdammt alt aussehen lassen in diesem
video werden wir uns nicht mit
worthülsen abspeisen lassen mit denen
sich kein normaler bürger wirklich
identifizieren kann nein heute wird es
neben den gefahren die auf ihn zu
bekommen vor allem um chancen geht um
die chance eines aufbruchs unseres
kontinents in ein neues goldenes
zeitalter
wir werden euch zeigen wie wir in jede
not geraten sind vor der viele so lange
die augen verschlossen haben und die wir
aus dieser not eine tugend machen können
denn die vor uns liegenden
herausforderungen bergen jenen keim der
hoffnung endlich dass wir letzten endes
als strahlende sieger aus ihnen empor
steigen könnten und zwar nicht nur als
sieger über einen äußeren feind sondern
auch als sieger an der heimatfront
sieger über den eigenen niedergang den
verfall unserer werte und kräfte in dem
sich europa seit jahrzehnten befindet
habe als erstes muss die ganze wahrheit
auf den tisch weite strecken diese
videos werden sehr schmerzhaft für uns
alle sein aber wir müssen da durch nur
so können wir eine tragfähige lösung
finden und ja noch haben wir es in der
hand wenn wir die richtigen schritte
wählen werden wir aus dieser krise
gestärkt hervorgehen putin wird dann
nichts weiter als ein nadelstich gewesen
sein ein nadel sticht der unsere
selbstheilungsprozesse wieder in schwung
gebracht hat und es liegt ganz an uns
und den politikern die wir wählen werden
auf diese langen wanderung die risiken
oder die chancen ob 7 seid ihr gespannt
gehabt allen grund dazu also macht euch
bereit verfangen sofort an
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die länder der europäischen union haben
jahrzehnte lang zu wenig für die
verteidigung getan vor allem zu wenig
geld ausgegeben und wenn ich zu wenig
geld sage dann meine ich damit in erster
linie weniger als sie gemäss ihren
verpflichtungen gegenüber den anderen
nato verbündeten hätten ausgeben sollen
laut des gründungsvertrag der nato
sollten alle mitgliedsstaaten mindestens
zwei prozent ihres bip in
landesverteidigung unsicherheit
investieren tja und jetzt schaut euch
mal an wie die realität aussieht
die rot markierten länder sind
diejenigen die ihren verpflichtungen
nicht einhalten wie du siehst hat mit
ausnahme von frankreich polen und ein
paar anderen fast kein land seine
verpflichtungen erfüllt und das ist seit
fast 30 jahren der fall allgemein kann
man nämlich feststellen dass nach dem
fall des eisernen vorhangs alle
europäischen länder ihrer
verteidigungshaushalte jahr für jahr
heruntergefahren haben die
kontinuierliche unterfinanzierung der
landesverteidigung ist jedoch nur ein
symptom das symptom einer politischen
und vor allem gesellschaftlichen des
ballons die auf einem grundlegenden
unverständnis natürliche
gesetzmäßigkeiten droht große teile
unserer gesellschaft und politik sind
dem irrglauben verfallen der mensch
würde mittlerweile irgendwie außerhalb
der evolution stehen er hätte sich über
seine biologischen ursprünge erhoben und
müsse nun die mechanismen um
naturgesetze auf den sie bewohnen nicht
mehr auf sich selbst beziehen ja welche
fataler und überheblicher druck schluss
wir alle stecken so tief in der
evolution drin die eh und je
[Applaus]
die spitze dieses denkt der eisbergs
bildete anfang der neunzigerjahre presse
ist tobias scheel analyse wir wirken
nach dem fall des eisernen vorhangs am
ende der geschichte steht gemeint war
dass wir krieg und gewalt nicht nur als
mittel politischen handelns erleben
würde jeder population existiert eine
evolutionär stabile strategie kurs es
welche ihre existenzfähigkeit gegenüber
anderen populationen sicherstellt unsere
spezies bildet wie jede andere
verschiedene populationen aus welche
sich durch gemeinsame merkmale die
geografie ideologie oder gar biologie
definieren und auch gegenüber anderen
populationen mehr oder weniger abgrenzen
im rahmen der ss muss sich in jeder
population das verhältnis zwischen den
sogenannten falken also aggressiven und
starten individuen und den sogenannten
tauben also friedlichen und
ausweichenden individuen in einer
gesunden balance finden sowohl russland
als auch westeuropa haben ihre
evolutionär stabile strategie verloren
russland ist ein fast reinen falten
staat geworden und europa hat seine
falken vollkommen ausgerottet dafür
haben sich dort die tauben vermehrt wie
die karnickel
jeglicher respekt vor dem militär als
überlebenswichtige institution des
landes und der demokratie wurde gezielt
zertrümmert und damit die
gesellschaftliche und politische
akzeptanz nicht nur dazu geschaffen das
militär auszuhungern sollte es zudem in
jeder erdenklichen form für ideologische
oder partikularinteressen zu in pfronten
und geradezu zu missbrauchen dies fängt
mit dem zuschalten lukrative aufträge an
politiker freund an und hört mit der
verzögerung der auslieferung von
schützenpanzern auf bald diese auch für
hoch schwangere soldatinnen geeignet
sein müssten und für den kreml waren das
einfach schon zu viele lachnummern die
sie bei ihrem gegenüber mit ansehen
mussten
vielleicht bekommt ihr deswegen mit der
angst zu tun und musste zu schlagen weil
er sich an diese monty python folge mit
dem tödlichen biss erinnert hat mein
gott sie arbeiten nicht nur in einem
tödlichen wird sie sind dabei die ganze
bundeswehr in einen tödlichen witz zu
verwandeln tja und damit hatte er wohl
auch recht wenn auch nicht zu einem
tödlichen biss für ihn sondern europa
und die ukraine denn diese ganze
irrwitzige entwicklung erklärt warum der
überfall wladimir putin es gewagt hat in
die ukraine einzumarschieren während er
erwartete dass europa tatenlos zusieht
die eine brave traube ausreicht um einen
konflikt in jedem kreis aus dem wege zu
gehen nicht die aufnahme neuer länder in
die nato sondern die evolutionär
unausgewogen und einseitige tauben
strategie europas und das tatenlose zu
sehen die putin sein land nach und nach
in eine reinrassige zweiten zucht
verwandelt sind dafür verantwortlich
dass nun wieder krieg in europa herrscht
[Musik]
zwischen dem westen und russland
herrschen nicht irgendwelche
missverständnisse wie man wieder
irgendwie vertraut voll ausräumen könnte
sondern fundamentale gegensätze im
verständnis nationale souveränität dem
selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker und
der kulturellen gesellschaftlichen
ordnung europas sämtliche osteuropäische
staaten die der nato beigetreten sind
genießen frieden wohlstand und
stabilität diejenigen staaten die den
beitrag nicht geschafft haben sind
massiv in ihrer souveränität und
demokratischen entfaltung bedroht und
haben kriegerische konflikte mit
russischen truppen auf ihrem territorium
[Musik]
dieser konflikt wird auch nach einem
ende des ukraine kriegs lange weiter
bestehen und die europäische realität
auf generationen prägen aber gut da die
naturwissenschaftlichen grundlagen
ungeklärt sind lasst uns wieder zur bio
politik zurückkehren denn der habe so
einige fragen zu klären
[Musik]
zum einen woher soll das geld für die
neue falten also den militärausgaben her
kommen werden sie nur eine belastung für
uns sein oder könnte dies eine
gelegenheit für europäische unternehmen
darstellen wie der zur weltspitze
aufzuschließen könnte putins
aggressionen gar die einmalige chance
für europa sein sein abgleiten in die
stagnation zu durchbrechen heute werden
wir all diese fragen natürlich
beantworten aber zuerst lasst uns jedem
land helfen welches gerade die hölle auf
erden durchlebt um sich und europa vor
den horden des tyrannen zu verteidigen
die zentralbank der ukraine den spenden
aus dem ganzen welt an um den widerstand
und die ukrainischen streitkräfte zu
unterstützen und ich habe euch den links
und ihrer spenden derzeit in die
beschreibung unter dieses video gepackt
bitte denkt daran es geht nicht um eine
abstrakte beistandspflicht es geht um
grundsätze und die verteidigung eines
landes das versucht verstaatlicht zu
werden frei und unabhängig zu sein genau
deswegen ist die ukraine ja ein dorn im
auge putins eine demokratische und
erfolgreiche ukraine ist der absolute
gegenentwurf zu seinem hass und despotie
versinkenden russland und putin versucht
nicht einen diktator al assad oder
hussein zu stürzen sondern einen
demokratisch gewählten präsidenten es
ist unglaublich kurzsichtig dass leute
im westen auch nur in erwägung ziehen
die ukraine soll es sich ergeben
angeblich um
zu vermeiden dabei geht es nicht nur
darum dass putin dann quasi zum
nulltarif eine große und wie wir jetzt
sehen sehr potente armee in die hände
fallen würde mit der europa noch stärker
bedrohen könnte es geht um unsere ja
unsere wertegemeinschaft welche die
ukraine bis auf ihr eigenes blut
verteidigen eine wertegemeinschaft die
den frieden und die freiheit genauso
lieben sollte wie ihre wehrhaftigkeit
und es ist besonders tragisch dass
gerade jene leute die sich mit parteien
identifizieren welche eigentlich aus dem
freiheitskampf entstanden sind nun den
freiheitskämpfern in der ukraine derart
in den rücken fallen die ukraine hält
sich ja nur dank ihrer nach 2010 wieder
lang im inneren balance zwischen falken
und tauben dass du es daher zuerst einen
blick in die geschichte werfen um
herauszufinden wie der weg zur
wiedererlangung eines gesamteuropäischen
gleichgewichts aussehen muss wie finden
wir wieder zu unserer evolution eher
stabil strategie
[Applaus]
als wir alle noch pazifisten waren
im jahr 2018 trump damit die usa aus der
nato aussteigen zu lassen hätte er seine
drohung wahrgemacht wäre die nato zu
diesem zeitpunkt aufgelöst worden klar
es war eine dieser nicht wirklich ernst
gemeinten junction drohkulissen mit
denen er seine partner wachrütteln
wollte aber glaubt mir allein diese
andeutung hat erhebliche wellen
geschlagen uns viele staatsoberhäupter
rund um die welt bringen schon an zu
feiern damals ging der französische
präsident immer noch einmal kranker so
weit zu sagen die nato sei hirntot und
heute würde er sich wohl wünschen alle
würden diese seine worte am besten
vergessen aber ihr müsst zugeben dass
trump in diesem moment nicht ganz
unrecht hatte denn er hat im gegensatz
zu vielen anderen erkannt dass die
miserabel einstellung der übrigen nato
partner gegenüber ihrem militär ihre
abwehrbereitschaft und ihren
verpflichtungen bei den militärausgaben
geradezu eine einladung für
militaristische möchte darstellt diese
schwäche zum geeigneten zeitpunkt
auszunutzen und einem großen krieg und
zu brechen schließlich wusste bereits
platin auch später die römer liebespaar
camp parabellum wenn du frieden willst
bereitet sich auf den krieg vor aber die
europäer scheren sich nun mal weder um
ihre eigene geschichte noch um die
grundlagen ihrer angeblichen werte jeder
werte die sie eigentlich gar nicht
verdient haben denn sie mussten sie sich
ja auch nicht verdienen sie genießen
gerne all ihre freiheiten
unannehmlichkeiten die ihre vorfahren
für sie einst hart und ihrem eigenen
blut erkämpfen mussten aber nicht nur
ihre eigenen vorfahren auch die der
amerikaner und deswegen dachten sie so
könne es einfach für immer weiter gehen
sie wussten dass sie im falle einer
echten bedrohung immer auf die
unterstützung von anderes seinen zählen
konnten warum sollte man sich dann noch
selbst bemühen oder gar die finger
schmutzig machen wir zu anlocken und so
teuren dingen die einer echten armee mit
der folgenden grafik sich zum beispiel
die militärausgaben deutschlands
in den 1960 er jahren als die bundeswehr
noch aufgebaut werden musste gab
deutschland 5 prozent seines bip für die
verteidigung aus und damals dürfte der
anteil der pension noch verschwindend
gering gewesen sein in den 1970 er und
80 er jahren ging diese ausgaben zurück
und erreicht mit 90 nur noch 2,5 prozent
und nach 1990 also nachdem der eiserne
vorhang fiel sagte sie dramatisch auf
nur knapp über ein prozent deutschland
ist ein extrembeispiel aber derselbe
trend ist in fast allen anderen
europäischen ländern zu beobachten gut
auf den ersten blick erschien die
abrüstungspolitik durchaus sinnvoll zu
sein ich meine aus welchem grund wurde
die nato den ursprünglich gegründet und
warum haben die usa und westeuropa in
den 80er jahren so viel für rüstung
ausgegeben klar weil es mit der
sowjetunion eine echte bedrohung gab
aber nach ihrer auflösung schien all der
riesenaufwand nicht mehr angebracht zu
sein ja europa hat auch danach noch
kriege geführt die millennials die sich
dieses video ansehen haben mindestens
einen davon erlebt den balkankriegen ein
krieg in den auf die nato angegriffen
hat aber am balkan konflikt war keine
andere großen supermacht beteiligt die
über atomwaffen verfügt die großen
traditionellen kriege scheinen der
vergangenheit anzugehören und nach nine
eleven soll der terrorismus zum neuen
feind nummer eins der freien welt
plötzlich sagen die bösewichte in den
filmen nicht mehr aus wie dieser typ
sondern eher weg dieser im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert wird auf
allen sicherheits konferenzen und foren
über neue konzepte wie
terrorismusbekämpfung cyber sicherheit
und hybride kriegsführung gesprochen
diese umfrage sagt alles
hier siehst du dass die oberste
militärische priorität europa nordafrika
war gefolgt vom nahen osten denkt mal
darüber nach eine band wie al qaida oder
da es zu bekämpfen ist eine
herausforderung aber es ist eine relativ
billige herausforderung man braucht
dafür keine riesiges stehendes er keine
flugzeugträger und keine atom u boote
selbst viele verteidigungsexperten
hielten daher hohe militärausgaben nicht
mehr für notwendig natürlich gab es auch
jenen darunter diese politik welche die
neue heraufziehende gefahr und den sich
daraus ergebenden bedarf schon früh
erkannt hatten vor allem nach putins
annexion der krim und der in russland
sich intensivieren den staatlich
gelenkten militaristischen
indoktrination der bevölkerung wie so
oft üblich wurden diese unbequeme
expertisen jedoch von der politik
unterdrückt als alarmismus minderheit
meinung und geschwurbel diskreditiert
auch die neue deutsche
verteidigungsministerin langstrumpf oder
lambrecht oder diese gerade heißt hatte
nach ihrem amtsantritt nichts besseres
zu tun als die von generalinspekteur
zorn auf den weg gebrachten notwendige
reformen erst mal bis auf weiteres zu
vertagen tja die ps waren bei ihrem
marsch durch die institutionen nun ganz
oben angekommen und gaben vor was der
fachliche konsens zu sein habe ihr aller
motto von merkel über von der leyen bis
agata lautete sein
ihr drei macht neune
niemand mehr
mir geht
und jetzt denkt nicht diese
selbstzerstörerische attitüde hätte
irgendwas mit dem geschlecht oder der
nationalität dieser politiker zu tun so
gut wie ganz europa war von ihr gefallen
pedro sanchez das
verteidigungsministerium ist zu groß und
das budget zur armutsbekämpfung ist zu
klein für diejenigen die ihn nicht
kennen pedro sanchez ist der aktuelle
ministerpräsident spanier ist ja wie man
sieht auch eine ganz große leuchte ein
gigant geopolitischer kompetenz
mannomann in den letzten 20 jahren haben
die europäischen regierungen nicht nur
ihre militär budgets gekürzt sie haben
das militär auch für aufgaben
zweckentfremdet ja geradezu missbraucht
die nur sehr wenig bis gar nichts mit
verteidigung zu tun hatten spanien zb
der 2005 die military im medizinisch
begründet eine art feuerwehr die aus dem
verteidigungshaushalt bezahlt wird so
gibt es in spanien ganze einheiten die
überhaupt nicht mehr für den
kampfeinsatz ausgebildet sind klar sie
sollte für humanitäre aufgaben
eingesetzt werden aber ohne die
nächstens grundlegende verteidigungs
ausbildung können sie in kriegsgebieten
noch nicht mal diese aufgabe wahrnehmen
dass es keine kritik an der humanitären
arbeit drinnen ersthelfern du weißt dass
wir hier bei visual politik einen tiefen
respekt vor den streitkräften haben aber
die fakten sind klar fast ganz europa
hat seine verteidigung behandelt als
wäre sie ein bisschen
wir haben sogar so unverschämte
vorschläge wie diesen gesehen auf dem
weg zu einer klima sicheren sicherheits
und verteidigungspolitik ein fahrplan
für eu maßnahmen ja das ist richtig
irgendwann kam jemand in brüssel wohl
aus langer langeweile auf die idee das
doch eigentlich der klimawandel bei den
streitkräften die absolute priorität
darstellen sollte die armee solle ihre
bürger nicht mehr gegen putins granaten
verteidigung gegen co2 und den
temperaturanstieg versteh mich nicht
falsch wir sagen nicht dass der
temperaturanstieg gar keine
aufmerksamkeit verdient aber im falle
eines krieges mit ihr eine sekunde
zeiten stell dir vor das gerade jetzt
eines soldaten in der ukraine die kugeln
für sein maschinengewehr ausgehen weil
die beschaffung kein geld mehr hatte für
genügend biologisch abbaubare und
klimaneutral hergestellte munition mit
nachhaltigkeitszertifikat diese dinge
sind an realitätsferne kaum noch zu
überbieten und mehr als 30 jahre lang
waren die federführenden politiker in
europa davon überzeugt dass es keinen
krieg mehr gehen würde klingt das nicht
lächerlich angesichts dessen was putin
in den letzten jahren getan und von sich
gegeben hat und angesichts dessen dass
europa ihnen durch sein handeln geradezu
eine einladung nach der anderen das
sogar tja putin hat die einladung
europas nun angenommen john lennon ist
zum zweiten mal erschossen worden und
europa steht vor dem scherbenhaufen
seiner fehlgeleiteten friedenspolitik
schauen wir uns diesen scherbenhaufen
doch mal an also schon mal die kosten
[Musik]
wenn du frieden willst sei auf krieg
vorbereitet
wir haben es in den letzten tagen schon
mehrfach gesagt putin hat den krieg
bereits verloren ganz gleich was in der
ukraine passiert wladimir putins
übergeordnetes ziel war es die
ausdehnung der nato zu beenden jahre
lang sah es so aus als würde er damit
durchkommen in europa hatte keine
militärische abschreckung mehr zu bieten
deswegen hat er gesagt warum sollte ich
es nicht mal versuchen aber als erster
tat fing alles an sich zu verändern
neutrale finden und schweben überdenken
die idee einer nato-mitgliedschaft und
dass diese freunde ist erst der anfang
die baltischen staaten haben die usa
bereits gebeten militärstützpunkte auf
ihren territorien zu errichten ja genau
putin hat die usa quasi davon entbunden
sich an die vereinbarung zu halten in
den ehemaligen ländern des warschauer
pakts keine permanenten militärbasen zu
unterhalten bravo wladimir gut gemacht
aber damit es hier zu keinen
missverständnissen kommt es waren nicht
die usa die gesagt haben wir würden so
gerne einen militärstützpunkt in estland
errichten nein es war die estnische
regierung selbst die gesagt hat bitte
kommt und bleibt baut bitte eure
militärbasen bei uns denn wir haben
angst nach der ukraine den nächsten zu
sein und dann kam sogar der deutsche
bundeskanzler olaf scholz mit
ankündigung ein sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro für die wiederaufrüstung
der bundeswehr aufzustellen und seine
verwendung gar zur chefsache zu machen
oh je das nur der chef-sache kennen wir
doch woher das hat nicht merkel alles
zur chefsache gemacht digitalisierung
und wir wissen ja was daraus geworden
ist kommt euch das ganze nicht irgendwie
auch komisch vor angela merkel war 60
jahre lang die chefin 60 jahre lang gab
sie vor das ziel der ostdeutschen
ostpolitik sei frieden und stabilität
und dabei betrieb sie im hintergrund
jene populistische
beschwichtigungspolitik die diesen tag
erst ermöglicht hat sie wollte den
deutschen michel einfach nicht wach
rütteln dieser tausch freiheit die er
sehr gerne gegen sicherheit und
natürlich bequemlichkeit und nun ist die
landesverteidigung auch noch in die
hände von pippi langstrumpf und ihrem
chef dem scholz formaten gefallen ein
empathischer parteifunktionäre
zahlreiche korruptionsskandale belastet
und wohl auch erpressbar geworden ist
und dessen partei ist in weiten teilen
haupt eng mit der kreml macht ja
getrieben hat und isst am liebsten noch
weiter treiben würde wie läuft
eigentlich mit diesen parteiausschluss
von gas kehrt dessen ehemaliger
langjähriger büroleiter und
kanzleramtschef heute übrigens was ist
genau bundespräsident na ja der hat aber
bestimmt auch von nichts gewusst so wie
auch scholz in sachen wirecard max und
so weiter und so fort und diese ehrbaren
leute wollen nun also 100 milliarden
euro ausgeben und dazu noch das
grundgesetz ändern um darin
verteidigungsausgaben in höhe von
mindestens zwei prozent des bip zu
verankern und das letzte was sie dabei
im sinn haben sind sicherlich ihre
netzwerke amigos und saftige kickbacks
was für ein glück für deutschland und
ganz europa tja john lennon ist tot und
jetzt hören wir alle nur noch sabaton
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eine frage ist jedoch auch leer dieses
schönen und konzert nun bezahlen soll
denn es ist sehr einfach zu sagen lasst
uns mehr für die verteidigung ausgeben
aber was bedeutet es eigentlich mehr
flugzeuge kaufen mehr soldaten anheuern
nun schauen wir mal neuer bericht zeigt
dass das deutsche militär immer noch
unter ressourcenmangel leidet in diesem
bericht des deutschen bundestages steht
dass keines der deutschen u boote und
kampfflugzeuge bereit ist und das ist
nur die spitze des eisbergs der
inspekteur des heeres generalleutnant
als von mais drückt es so aus dass her
steht mehr oder weniger lang da die
deutschen streitkräfte sind zur landes-
und bündnisverteidigung kaum befähigt
und könnte dadurch ihren
verfassungsmäßigen auftrag nicht
erfüllen dies fängt bei einem
gigantischen mangel an material waffen
und ausrüstung an zieht sich über die
furchtbare beschaffungs bürokratie und
die total vernachlässigte
führungsfähigkeit auf brigade und
divisionsebene bis hin zu einer
wenigstens angemessenen digitalisierung
der landstreitkräfte wir lachen uns zur
zeit schlapp über die schlechte logistik
der russischen armee wir wachen darüber
dass die russen keine verschlüsselte
kommunikation nutzen so dass die ukraine
sieg problemlos abhören können wir
wundern uns dass ihre unteroffiziere so
unfähig sind das die kommandeure und
generäle höchstselbst an den vordersten
front linien für ordnung sorgen müssen
statt das geschehen sicher und überlegen
von ihren tiefständen zu überblicken und
zu steuern und dann halt von
scharfschützen abgeknallt werden die
frei wild fakt ist jedoch die bundeswehr
würde in all diesen punkten
wahrscheinlich ein noch viel trauriges
bild abgeben
wir sprechen von eklatanten
personalmangel sowohl quantitativ als
auch qualitativ von einer reinen
mangelverwaltung und absenz digitaler
führungsfähigkeit ich sag nur 140 jahre
alte funkgeräte damit wir uns nicht
falsch verstehen dies ist nicht die
schuld der soldaten und ihren
militärischen führung diese hat seit der
annexion der krim alles auf den tisch
gelegt ist mit ihren argumenten jedoch
nie bei der politik durchgekommen selbst
innerhalb dieser langen acht jahre habe
die wechselnden verteidigungsminister
nicht kapiert dass die bundeswehr eine
doktrin ehre kehrtwende hinlegen muss
sich organisatorisch von ihrer
ausrichtung auf auslandseinsätze lösen
und für die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung fit machen muss um
damit zu ihrer historischen aufgabe
zurückzufinden den massiven
verteidigungs verzögerungs und
gegenangriff operationen in der nordost
europäischen titel dadurch
fähigkeitsprofil der eu und nato armeen
komplementär zueinander ausgelegt sind
kann außer der deutschen bundeswehr
keine von ihnen die nötigen heeres
kräfte stellen um die ostflanke der nato
gegen russland zu sichern deswegen kommt
es vor allem auf das deutsche heer an
und seien für eine glaubhafte
friedenserhaltende abschreckung
notwendiges fähigkeitsprofil nämlich die
schnelle verleger fähigkeit von gross
verbänden und die mobilisierung von
reserve einheiten welches obendrein noch
gar nicht gibt damit jedem klar wird
wovon hier die rede ist das deutsche
heer erzählt 63.000 soldaten und 266
panzer das polnische 100.000 soldaten
und 863 panzer frankreich 150.000
soldaten und 406 panzer gesetzt und die
hehre dieser drei großen nato-länder
zusammenzählen kommen wir nur auf
278.000 soldaten und 1535 panzer so und
jetzt vergleichen wir das mal mit der
ukraine
diese rate 200.000 soldaten das nur noch
250.000 reservisten und
2596 panzer damit ist das heer der
ukraine größer als die deutschlands
frankreichs und puls zusammengenommen
versteht er jetzt warum auch nur ein
gedanke daran die ukraine solle sich
putin ergeben nicht nur von
unverfrorenen defätismus zeugt sondern
auch von vollkommener ahnungslosigkeit
und kurzsichtigkeit ich sehe mich hier
schon fast genötigt solchen leuten die
allgemeine denkfähigkeit abzusprechen
ich meine was stellen sie sich vor was
danach passieren würde die russen würden
diese gewaltige streit macht und all
ihre waffen in ihre reihen eingliedern
und dann ja dann hätte europa
wahrscheinlich wirklich keine chance
mehr was heute tief und cafés sind
werden morgen warschau und krakau und
übermorgen berlin und frankfurt und
putin würde überhaupt nicht mehr lügen
müssen um zu sagen alles läuft ganz nach
plan denn wenn sich die ukraine ergeben
würden und russland dann weiter die nato
angreifen würde hätte die bundeswehr in
ihrem derzeitigen zustand keine
möglichkeit zu reagieren zumindest
erstmal nicht vor mehreren wochen ihrer
kaltstart fähigkeit ist gleich null
und das ist nicht nur in deutschland so
fast alle europäischen armeen haben das
gleiche problem die wenigen waffen die
sie haben werden in hangars gelagert und
warum weil es teuer ist ein
kampfflugzeug ab bereitzuhalten sehr
teuer ohne moos ist nun mal nichts los
und die defizite sind in all den jahren
zu einem riesigen berg an problemen
herangewachsen es ist also klar dass von
einer echten aufrüstung noch lange nicht
die rede sein kann die geplanten
schritte geld nur einer teilweisen
wiederherstellung von fähigkeiten die
bundeswehr damals zumal in weitere maße
früher schon besaß selbst die jetzt
gesteckte ziel nachteil entspricht
gerade einmal 25 prozent der anzahl
gepanzerter kampfverbände der bundeswehr
aus dem jahr 1990 kaputt gespart wurden
jedoch nicht nur die europäische städte
sondern auch ihre ausrüster die
europäische rüstungsindustrie erinnerst
du dich an die s35 über die wir auf
diese art politik schon so oft
gesprochen haben es sieht so aus als
wären die europäischen armeen und darauf
angewiesen eine ganze menge dieser
kampfjets aus den usa zu bestellen und
das ist nicht auf den druck der usa
zurückzuführen
es liegt einfach nur daran dass europa
nach jahrzehntelangen mageren böden und
wenige waffen hersteller hat die mit den
amerikanern noch konkurrieren können
wenn du also einen hochmodernen kampfjet
willst hast du heute keine andere wahl
als die s25 zu kaufen
aber wartet einen moment ich weiß dass
viele von euch denken vor allem
diejenigen von euch die etwas von
militär und verteidigung verstehen
endlich sagt jemand die ungeschminkte
wahrheit aber woher soll eigentlich das
ganze geld kommen um all das zu
finanzieren
die liste der dringenden lebenswichtigen
prioritäten und existenziellen notlage
in europa ist länger denn je eine durch
lockt bei uns aus der balance geratene
wirtschaft währung und verschuldung die
überhastete energie und verkehrswende
der sinnfreie atomausstieg die
rohstoffabhängigkeit von russland
explodierendes sozial und
lebenshaltungskosten und steuersätze
schiffbau stoff düngemittel und bald
vielleicht auch lebensmittelknappheit
und das alles wird in den kommenden
monaten noch viel schlimmer werden die
frage ist also was kann man tun wir
haben da eine idee
[Musik]
zwei fliegen mit einer klappe schlagen
warum gibt es eigentlich kein
europäisches google diese frage haben
wir auch visuell politik schon
tausendfach gestellt denn um es klar zu
sagen in der antwort auf sie vereinen
sich alle grundlegenden probleme des
impotent gewordenen kontinents ohne
innovation und führende unternehmen wird
es in zukunft kein wirtschaftswachstum
geben und ohne funktionierende
wirtschaft gibt es keinen sozialstaat
keinen kampf gegen den klimawandel und
auch keine verteidigung und nein wir
reden hier nicht von ihnen teilen der
wirtschaft die von russischen billig gas
abhängig sind diese sind nichts mehr
motor mit dem europa seine weltweite
konkurrenz im innovationsrat rennen
schlagen kann die frage lautet daher
warum hängt europa bei allen neuen
technologischen revolutionen immer
hinterher nun ja einige werden sagen
europa hat sehr hohe steuersätze aber
das ist es nicht wenn der region für
region vergleichen hat estland keine
höheren steuersätze als zb kalifornien
demografie bildung rechtssicherheit und
gesundheitswesen in all diesen punkten
steht europa nicht viel schlechter da
als erfolgreiche regionen in manchen
sogar viel besser in einem bereich
sticht der mangel an innovation in
europa jedoch deutlich heraus welcher
das ist genau das militär
genauer gesagt die niedrigen und dazu
noch zweckentfremdeten investitionen in
die streitkräfte natürlich ist es nicht
der einzige und vielleicht auch nicht
der wichtigste grund aber er ist ein
verdammt wichtiger grund und er hat das
potenzial zusammen mit einer
gesellschaftlich moralischen wende zu
einem echten game changer zu erwerben
denkt mal drüber nach israel südkorea
und die usa sind technologisch
hochgradig innovative länder und zwar
vor allem dank ihres militärs und der
resilienz ihrer bevölkerung
[Musik]
das silicon valley ist unter anderem
deshalb entstanden weil das militär dort
ein entwicklungszentrum für
telekommunikation eingerichtet hat tja
und google oder was gäbe es heute kein
google genau ohne das internet und ohne
was gäbe es kein internet genau ohne das
us militär tatsächlich wurde das
internet als ein us verteidigungs
projekt geboren es ging aus dem bett
hervor benannt nach der advanced
research projects agency des pentagon
damals während des kalten kriegs lautete
die zielsetzung systeme zu entwickeln
die den betrieb auch bei teilweiser
zerstörung zum beispiel durch einen
atomkrieg aufrechterhalten können ein
projekt an dem in der privatwirtschaft
in den 60er jahren niemand interesse
hatte zumindest nicht an dessen
finanzierung und ich weiß dass viele von
euch jetzt einwenden werden echt jetzt
werk seit wann ist der staat in der lage
forschung und entwicklung effektiv zu
fördern wir alle wissen doch jedes mal
wenn eine regierung eine bestimmte
technologie entwickeln will scheitert
sie kläglich jeden tag können wir über
solche beispiele in der zeitung lesen
und ja im grunde habt ihr recht aber
zwischen zivilen und militärischen
forschungs und entwicklungsprojekten
gibt es einen großen unterschied
[Musik]
bei letzteren haben die staaten selbst
in den sehr starken einreißen zu
entwickeln mit denen sie mit dem pfand
konkurrieren können so dass die
anwendung der forschungsarbeit im
vordergrund steht natürlich kommt es
auch hier regelmäßig zu großen
budgetüberschreitung ein beispiel dafür
ist gerade die s35 über die wir hier
auch fußball politik ausführlich
berichtet haben aber auch in diesem fall
ist das endergebnis der tödlichste kauft
at den es derzeit gibt
[Musik]
ist er teuer ja aber er ist eine waffe
die unübertroffen ist die amerikanische
rüstungsindustrie kann jetzt mit ihr den
großen reibach einfahren darüber hinaus
werden aber viele jener technologien die
für die s35 entwickelt wurden viele neue
startups hervorbringen welche auch mit
der zivilen nutzung der technologien
großen nutzen für die gesellschaft hohe
profite für sich und hohe
steuereinnahmen für den staat generieren
werden mit anderen worten ausgaben für
die verteidigung haben einen zivilen
nutzen die positiven rückkopplung und
zweitrundeneffekte können gewaltig sein
europa muss sich also unbedingt von der
us rüstungsindustrie unabhängig machen
und wieder selbst zu einem epizentrum
der militärtechnologie werden das
potenzial dazu ist allemal vorhanden die
ressourcen müssen einfach nur richtig
amüsiert werden daher ist es durchaus
nicht unlustig eine großen teil dieser
neuen militärausgaben nicht aus neuen
steuern oder schulden zu finanzieren
sondern aus anderen ausgabenposten die
für die zivile forschung bestimmt waren
in erster linie sollten wir natürlich
erst mal alle mittel für gender studies
und ähnlichen wert versetzen des
telefons komplett umleiten aber im ernst
diese mittel die es in alle möglichen
zivilen projekte mit eher fraglich im
fokus fließen und glaube mir dass es
eine ganze menge müssen jetzt
schnellstmöglich militärischen projekten
zugute kommen die früher oder später
dann auch zivil nutzen haben werden denn
die erfahrungen der erfolgreichen länder
zeigen militärausgaben zu innovationen
finden in der regel in viel stärkerem
maße eine reale umsetzung und werden
erfolgreich eingesetzt als andere
öffentliche forschungsausgaben in israel
zum beispiel hat das militär dazu
beigetragen die innovationen anderen
sektoren extrem zu pusten wenn es um die
ausgaben geht kann die militärische
forschung und entwicklung also bessere
ergebnisse erzielen als andere option
übrigens natürlich werde ich euch die
videos zu 35 und auch so
innovationskraft des israelischen
militärs in der beschreibung verlinken
und falls wir uns noch nicht abonniert
haben holt das doch jetzt schnell nach
und aktiviert auch das glöckchen um
keines unserer videos mit zu verpassen
ich danke euch aber zurück nach israel
israels verteidigungsausgaben von 5,6
prozent seines bip sind also einer der
gründe warum das kleine land zur startup
nation par excellence geworden ist und
dies ist nicht der einzige punkt den
sich europa von den israelis abschauen
kann weitere punkte sind seine absolute
und resolute wehrhaftigkeit und ebenso
eine über den verteidiger bereich hinaus
gehende stärke resilienz der
gesamtgesellschaft also statistisch
soldo moral kulturelle selbst hasst und
gender stern verseuchte
identitätspolitik brauchen wir wieder
eine bedingungslose fokussierung auf die
werte auf denen unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung tatsächlich
fußt die sie festigen nicht zu ersetzen
[Musik]
damit wir uns nicht falsch verstehen ich
spreche nicht davon dass wir hier stumpf
den russischen militarismus auskunft von
im gegenteil es geht um den positiven
gegen infos dazu die wiederherstellung
der wehrhaften demokratie
europa soll nicht aufhören pazifistisch
zu sein es darf nur nicht länger wehrlos
sein wir brauchen wieder ein gesundes
das heißt natürliches verhältnis von
tauben und falken statt empathie loser
wohlstandsverwöhnt und pseudo hlinka
waschlappen auch mir wieder ein wirklich
aufgeklärt und aufklären das bürgertum
welches bereit ist unsere demokratie so
not mit der waffe in der hand zu
verteidigen und ich sage ich ganz und
gar nicht aus irgendwelchen
ideologischen gründen nein es handelt
sich hierbei um eine gesellschaftliche
notwendigkeit ohne eine solide
verankerung der wehrhaftigkeit und damit
der bundeswehr in der gesellschaft kann
ihre wehr fähigkeit nicht erzielt werden
das sage ich nicht als philosoph sondern
als mathematiker um die vorhin
beschriebenen defizite aufgrund derer
die bundeswehr ihren verfassungsmäßigen
auftrag nicht erfüllen kann zu beheben
muss im rahmen der nato bis zum jahr
2032 drei personell und materiell voll
ausgestattete version mit acht bis zehn
kampfbrigaden aufstellen und gefechts
bereithalten wir sprechen hier von einem
gesamtumfang von 50 bis 60 tausend
soldaten für den kampf einsatz wodurch
sich für die bundeswehr eine zielgröße
von 200.000 dienstposten um eine reserve
von 120.000 ergibt unbemerkt wir
sprechen hier über das absolute minimum
und jetzt haltet euch fest selbst diese
untergrenze lässt sich aufgrund der
demografischen und edukativen
entwicklung mit der derzeitigen der form
in deutschland nicht realisieren weder
qualitativ noch qualitativ nun ist also
jener moment gekommen an dem wir am
beginn einer echten und
gesellschaftlichen reformen stehen einer
reform welche europa wieder beleben kann
unsere werte unsere wehrhaftigkeit
unsere demokratie unsere demographie und
unsere innovationskraft diese große
chance können wir nun ärger und müssen
wir auch ergreifen aber nun ist die
frage an euch gerichtet wird europa
eurer meinung nach die neuen
militärausgaben finanzieren können durch
höhere steuern und abgaben oder besser
durch umleitung von anderen ausgaben in
wie weit kann die bedrohung durch
russland eine chance sein dass eines
tages das dringend benötigte europäische
google entsteht wie immer sind wir auf
eure beiträge und diskussionen zu diesem
wichtigen thema schon sehr gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses video gefallen
hat und jeder weiß vielleicht auch etwas
gelernt habt falls ja geht uns mit einem
leisen freunden und vergesst nicht dass
aber mit glöckchen und keines unseren
videos nicht verpassen natürlich freunde
und auch jederzeit über eine spende von
euch mit der und hält dieses projekt das
für den peter link dazu finden ihren
beschreibung unter diesem video was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]